these liens don't need to worry where
that next meal will come from
millions of wildebeest zebras and
antelope traversed the Serengeti
National Park every year in the largest
mammal migration in the world
but the park is in danger
conservationists rhiannon lorna la busca
i have been working in national parks
for over 30 years now they're here in
the Serengeti fighting to protect its
animal populations any illegal poaching
or killing of animals is a problem for
that ecosystem because it put it out of
balance Deana Serengeti
here they use this snare which is
devastating on on big populations of
wildlife everything will be will be
killed
mostly Valle de beast zebra Impala but
if they put up a whole snare line
sometimes of over a hundred snares
whatever goes in there this patrol unit
is made up of Park Rangers and former
poachers they've collected more than 100
snares today most of the poachers come
from villages on the edge of the park
they know how to do it they've got years
and years and experienced animals walk
into the snare and the snare the cable
wire pulls tight around the neck or
sometimes around the foot and the animal
is then strangled and killed the animals
of the Serengeti know no borders there
are no fences in the park
and animals and humans live in close
proximity Massa Gary who died lives in
the Serengeti buffer zone his job is to
safeguard the park and that means
protecting it against humans the current
population of Tanzania is 50 million but
that could double in coming decades
population grows for the Serengeti means
more increased consumption of natural
resources and that means more pressure
for the wildlife bushmeat hunting and
also a grazing livestock that's
increasingly a big problem Serengeti
shall not die is a 1959 German
documentary written and directed by
benoît Tremec the Academy award-winning
film helped make the park world-famous
nearly 60 years later it's more topical
than ever
[Music]
we as frankfurt zoological society stand
a little bit away and look at the whole
picture from afar we can bring that
experience to the ground and help the
local management to be more effective in
what they doing back in the buffer zone
Massa Cary
Rory is visiting the new high school the
first and only one far and wide you know
the surrogate is one of the wonders of
the world yeah yeah so we have to keep
this endless by studying science subject
the children are eager to learn English
the second official language here after
Swahili until recently there was only an
elementary school in the area the new
high school was paid for with income
from tourism the children are also
taught how valuable the Serengeti is to
them and to the whole region so it needs
to be well looked after
[Music]